Paul Maloney asks you edited out a
disagreement with Camille Paglia what
was it no no that's not the case there
was a piece added it out but it wasn't
because there was a disagreement it was
because there was some glitch in the
video or something like that generally
speaking and you know I can't say this
with absolute certainty but I do and so
does my crew do everything we possibly
can to leave the videos alone except for
getting rid of things that would be of
no interest to anyone that our mistakes
so there was no disagreement are you
interested in coming to Australia yes
I've been invited a couple of times but
it hasn't worked out yet but my book
will be published in Australia I think
sometime in January as well and I
imagine that all be coming there at some
point in order to talk about my book and
so on Trey says how can a person go
through the future authoring process of
imagining a future for yourself as
though you or someone you care about
when you barely don't care about
yourself or even hate yourself yeah well
I would say that go through the exercise
anyways and and act as like try to
extend to yourself some courtesy you
know sometimes you have to act something
out before you can start to believe it
and so I would say sit down and pretend
that you're your friend you know Trey
the probability that there's something
so wrong with you that you don't deserve
any regard whatsoever is zero you know
so and I would say if if you just can't
get it together you know maybe you're
depressed and maybe you need to go talk
to someone because you don't have to be
depressed you talk to a physician you
know there are treatments for depression
if you happen to be depressed and if you
actually hate yourself then it's a
possibility that that's what's going on
I don't know how old you are but you
know there are effective treatments for
that sort of thing you might want to
find out if there's actually something
wrong physically or or psycho
physiologically you know because you
don't have to trudge through life
absolutely miserable there
antidepressants for example work really
well for some people not for everyone
but for some people